Well,
I probably should clarify my spoon full
of sugar.
The way with running with scissors,
the humor was like a spoonful of sugar,
makes the medicine go down.
That's true.
Just as humorous is a life raft in
terrible,
terrible circumstances.
It can kind of float you to the next
safe spot with running with scissors.
It's not that I would,
um,
sprinkle some sugar onto a.
I'm a bitter piece.
It's that I would just not,
I would leave out the bigger piece,
you know,
wolf at the table as much darker book,
Much Darker Book.
Both books though are like icebergs.
I'm tiny,
tiny little chunk above the surface of
the water.
Very small but yet kind of know what
else is underneath the water,
you know,
it's pretty much going to be the same
but more.
And for that reason,
the period of my life and running with
scissors was a lot more fun.
It was absolute madness
and I mean,
I didn't know how I was going to turn
out from that oven,
but it was fun.
But the time of my life before with my
father was not fun.
Um,
and in order to write that wolf book,
I had to,
um,
I had to go back in my head to that time
in Shutesbury,
Massachusetts and I had to,
um,
I had to be with him again and even
though I'm a lot older now and he's
dead,
uh,
that is,
you know,
interesting information that matters not
at all because these memories are very,
um,
they're very vivid,
very vivid.
So while I was writing that book,
um,
I was going through all the emotions,
you know,
you would go through during the,
I wouldn't want to do it again,
you know,
I wouldn't want to do it again.
It was not fun.
It was I'm not fun.
And I did it.
Um,
I kinda had to do it for me and then I
decided to publish it because I thought,
you know,
if I,
if I've learned anything from this
memoir thing,
it's that all the ways I thought I was a
freak.
It turns out there are other freaks that
are,
you know,
or people that have experienced the same
stuff.
So I bet there are a lot of other guys
or I thought of guys who had the same
father who went through the same thing,
and even if there's only a few of them,
this is going to be useful for them.
Um,
so that was the story over there with
that.